des tentes pour accueillir des milliers
de réfugiés vénézuélien parmi eux de
nombreux mineurs des personnes âgées et
des femmes enceintes
ils sont au moins 3000 à s'être arrêté
dans la ville colombienne darhaou kwita
après avoir fui les violences à la
frontière entre les deux pays
dépassé par la situation bogota a
demandé l'aide de la communauté
internationale
nous continuons à recevoir de nombreuses
personnes du pays voisins chaque fois
notre situation sur le terrain est plus
complexe
notre système de service public est sur
le point de s'effondrer
nous sommes à pleine capacité un exode
due à des affrontements entre les forces
armées vénézuéliennes et des dissidents
de l'ex guérilla des farc à la frontière
entre les deux pays
selon le service de renseignement
militaires colombiens ces bandes armées
seraient notamment financée par le
narcotrafic
nous nous interrogeons sur les
hostilités qui ont lieu au venezuela un
pays frère ou des civils ont été touchés
la population civile n'est pas
responsable des différents où des
affrontements militaires entre
organisations qu'elle soit légale ou
illégale dès le début des affrontements
dimanche dernier le président
vénézuélien nicolás maduro avait évoqué
ces combats à la télévision nous sommes
dans le cadre de l'opération bouclier
bolivarien qui protège notre frontière
face à l'abandon par la colombie de
toute sa frontière
ce qui permet à des groupes armés de
passer par la tolérance zéro pour les
groupes armés qui viennent de colombie
ce mercredi
caracas a dénoncé l' attaque contre des
civils et le déploiement de mines
antipersonnel par des groupes armés
colombien
malgré leur 2200 km de frontière commune
les relations diplomatiques entre le
venezuela et la colombie sont rompues
depuis la reconnaissance par bogota de
l'opposant et président autoproclamé
quang why do